avec la crise liée au public 19 à les
structures des compagnies les artistes
qui travaillent dans le domaine du
spectacle vivant qui est d'ailleurs la
catégorie que me subventionnés en plus à
la région ile de france
eh bien ils sont très très fortement
impacté parce que évidemment il ya les
annulations de spectacles
donc ça entraîne des conséquences
extrêmement préjudiciable pour ce milieu
et nous avons décidé d aider urgemment
il ya deux idées derrière ce volet le
premier c'est de garantir le versement
des sommes qui auraient été dues si les
prestations s'était déroulée normalement
et ce assez pour toutes les compagnies
structures avec lesquelles on passe des
accords avec les paul et ken on vote des
subventions donc au sein de la région
n'avait voté des subventions pour 2020
pour ses compagnes et ses structures
donc on leur garantit en absence parfois
de service fait le versement de la
totalité de la somme correspondant à la
prestation et pia deuxième volet donc
c'est le premier c'est 9 millions le
deuxième c'est en millions d'euros
c'est pour les structures les plus
fragiles avec lesquels on ne travaille
pas forcément c'est vous êtes un artiste
votre compagnie
votre association votre entreprise a
prévu un spectacle
et puis évidemment vous avez une perte
énorme anguilles et prix faute de
recettes
parce que ce spectacle est annulé donc
vous pourrez demander le remboursement à
hauteur de six à huit mille euros pour
la perte en billetterie et si par
exemple vous perdez 2000 euros mais on
vous remboursera les 2000 euros pour ça
il faut quand il faut quand même avoir
un engagement assez certain sur la sur
l'emploi
[Musique]
pour le spectacle vivant 10 millions
d'euros ça nous paraissait être une
somme très importante mais c'est
réaliste par rapport aux pertes de toute
façon courant mais nous allons refaire
un point avec les syndicats avec les
différents organismes et dans les autres
secteurs tels de secteur du livre de
secteur des galeries d'art secteur du
cinéma
nous avons déjà des points de travail
des moments de travail avec les
syndicats qui sont prévues certains
d'ailleurs ont déjà commencé et nous
allons pouvoir skis mais s'il n'y a
encore besoin de réévaluer notre aide